one of the top quarterback prospects
available in this year's draft joining
us right now on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line ole miss quarterback matt
corral how are you doing matt
i'm doing good how much so i'm doing
fine so um
what's april looking like for you right
now you got visits lined up walk me
through what uh what your week and rest
of the month looks like for you right
now well as soon as the combine ended uh
i got um you know
yeah i got the zoom meetings i got the
private workouts and
the visits
visits coming up starting next week um
was supposed to go to
new orleans
last thursday but due to weather we had
to postpone it
but you know tomorrow i'm going i'm
gonna go to orange county and uh
see my guy john beck and get some work
in and um you know
it's a constant work every single day
but uh
you know you gotta you gotta love it
because you know you only do this once
and i'm you know i'm about to start
doing what i was dreaming of doing when
i was a kid yeah i mean i guess this is
gonna be the most traveling in a month
you do um maybe for the rest of your
life you know
you never know so what's your itinerary
so you are you rescheduled new orleans i
imagine and and who else are you gonna
go pay a visit to what are you gonna say
i wanna say the uh
panther steelers um
wanna save
atlanta and uh there's uh eagles
okay so those are the ones that are
there any that you've already seen
outside of them
personally uh no i have no i mean i
remember going to the nflpa and i
remember visiting the the eagles
facility
i remember just being in awe going there
that was pretty it was a pretty cool fun
experience well then other than your
personal um your physical health and how
you're recovering from your bowl game
injury what's the most um often uh or
common question that's being asked of
you matt corral in this process
um
you know i would say just what type of
leader i am
and i think that's that's just a common
question that i've been asked frequently
and uh
you know i i just tell them like i'm a
servant leader and i wouldn't ask
anybody to do something that i would i
wouldn't do and
um you know they know that because i'm
constantly showing that on a day-to-day
basis
and that's the answer you you provide
what like give me the answer that you
provide to that no that is the answer
right okay
it's short and sweet but i mean it's um
you know it
it
it answers everything you know because i
mean you ask anybody in that facility
they'll they'll tell you
and what your decision to play in your
bowl game are you asked about that at
all matt uh yes sir i mean
the i mean
i've been asked i've been asked this
spring as well um
you know i i knew you know i would never
be in that position without you know my
teammates
um
you know specifically everybody that has
contributed from scout team to
you know
just being just uh just you know
you know being the ball boy i think i
feel like everybody
takes credit um
you know for being a part of being a
part of this you know the team that we
have
um
you know i
i would have never been in that spot
without those guys and i think that i
don't think they unders really
understood that because
you know it never crossed my mind that i
wasn't going to play the only reason why
i had to make it make it a thing and you
know announce that because people were
coming up to me on my team
asking me if i was going to play and
that had never even crossed my mind
and um
that was something that kind of you know
it was a curveball just because i didn't
think people would be thinking that but
i mean you know i let them know um i
want to say this was after the state
game our last game of the season and i
went in that next saturday and i just
wanted to let her that that friday and i
wanted to let them know that
you know
exactly what what i just said you know i
wouldn't be in this position without you
guys and you know i'm gonna give it all
until it's over well what was going
through your mind when you got hurt in
that game my my heart was in my throat
we've never met you know um i i i
i just watched that and i got sick to my
stomach
seeing that because i you know was
wanting to see you at the combine and
see you work out and i didn't know how
serious it was and things like that what
was going through your mind on the
sideline
first thought my first thought was my
family um
and then right after uh
my family was
was just my dream you know i just
thought it was over
i didn't know how bad or
you know what had happened but i just
knew it hurt it hurt a lot
and the pain wasn't wasn't settling at
all like it just kept going up and up
and up and i was just like this is not
good in my head and i just remembered
like
not being able to put weight on it and
it was scary it was scary definitely
just because i had no idea what happened
and you know i i'm grabbing my ankle i
can't feel it and
you know i'm blessed to to finally find
out that it was you know just a high
ankle sprain and there's no breaks or
tears
and you know that i made a full recovery
matt corral here on the rich eisen show
i heard your phone buzzed before was
that brett michaels texting you matt
no sir it was not okay it was not okay
have i i mean i i've talked to brett um
throughout this process he really wants
me to land a uh when pittsburgh
i was that was my next question because
he was here in studio last month uh matt
and he didn't need me to bring your name
up he was talking about you and your
family and he considers you family
and
loves you
and you know and man does he want you to
be the next quarterback of the
pittsburgh steelers in the worst way big
time yeah i mean i have the utmost
respect for the michaels family i mean
what they've done for me is you know
something that
something that i can never repay them
for you know they were there for me and
and in tough times and you know helping
me through and just showing me guidance
and you know being able to be there for
me when when i felt like nobody was and
that's something that i can you know
never repay them back for
but you know the michael's family there
you know brett brett's really pushing
really pushing mr rooney for the
for them to pick me
so oh so he's going top down not he's
that's what he's doing right now with
your evaluation in the steelers he's
he's going to the top and he's like
saying this is what you should drive me
i don't know specifically yes who i know
i know i mean he used to live next to
the gm one of the one of the owners of
the steelers i don't know who it was but
that was his neighbor and they they'd
always talk a lot and i know he brought
i know he brought my name up
well it's that's odd that brett would
talk i'll be honest to anybody you know
he's he's just uh honestly he was just
the greatest uh guest in the breath of
fresh air and he's just such a good how
long have you known him like what's your
what's the story
there um ever since i was a a freshman
in high school okay yeah i'm
towards the end of my freshman year of
high school i i met i met them and their
family and you know they're really great
people all around
really genuine down to earth people i
love it matt corral here on the rich
eisen show how much uh did you ever hear
from eli manning your
any connection
there and two cents that he might be
giving you in this process or throughout
your time at ole miss matt carrell yeah
i mean i i remember he would come into
the facilities and watch and uh
watch film with us and just um you know
ask ask questions here and there we were
when we would be watching film but
um you know eli he's
he's been a great communicator when i
when i've been asking questions just
because you know i want you know i just
wanted to pick his brain a little bit
and you know
he just told me to be myself and that's
honestly the best you know the best
advice i've ever gotten just because
you know you don't really understand
that until you're like towards the end
of this process to where it's like
you need to because it took a lot for me
to just be uh just to be just to be
myself in these interviews and
you know
don't don't try to make it you know
don't make it not authentic you know you
want to be real in them and you want to
you know show that you're you're not you
know just bs in your way through these
these interviews and
you know you really you really don't
have anything to lose if you just you
know be yourself you know you're going
to end up in the spot you're going to
end up at and that's something you have
no control over so might as well you
know
be yourself and not be somebody you're
not just so you can end up in the
correct spot that that will
that will build that would build you as
a player on and off the field for as
long as you're as long as you're there
and how is lane kiffin uh unlocked
anything for you matt
what do you got i mean just just being
there and you know giving me the
confidence i need just um
you know not necessarily just being
you know telling me everything good
about me and all that but he he pushed
me to be a great quarterback and a great
leader um at first
i'll never forget this he he told me
um before i was even a starter i
remember he just got out of meetings
saying that you know the slate's swipe
clean doesn't matter if you started here
last year or not um
we're we're trying to find put this team
together and there's no starters as of
right now
and i remember after the first two days
of
spring practice
you know
he told me like face to face like behind
after a meeting he told me that you know
you have you have elite arm talent and
you have you have the tools
of what it takes to be a great
quarterback at the next level and i
don't you know i've heard that i've
heard that a bunch of not a bunch of
times but like people have told me that
and
i don't know just when he told me that
it kind of hit differently just because
of you know who said it you know he's
been there and done that
so it's like okay maybe i'm not maybe i
am being too hard on myself and maybe i
need to start you know believing in
myself and having this confidence and
swag about myself that that i am that
dude yeah
what's the craziest piece of advice lane
kiffin has given you matt where you kind
of look i'm a coach really like has he
ever done that anything like that uh at
the top of my head i can't think of one
right now okay
um
all right i'll accept that yeah no off
the top of my head i can't think of
anything like i mean anything that's
crazy no i mean there's nothing that
he's told me that's too out there to
where it's like what did you just say
[Laughter]
i love that man oh so so so he hasn't
said hey when you speak to eli uh tell
uncle eli uh hello to his nephew for
from me he hasn't said that at all
okay
if you're while you're talking to eli
just tell them again because eli does
obviously know how great uh everything
is there at ole miss all right so uh are
you gonna be in vegas do you have plans
to be in las vegas on draft night matt
corral i'm currently figuring that out
with my age and my family right now okay
um
yeah i mean i they i i was presented the
opportunity too so um
you know i'm just thinking it over right
now and i think uh i think it's
something that i want to do but you know
i just got to make sure everyone's on
the same page of course no going up
there sure and so uh if you do that do
you have a suit already picked out do
you have something already
set uh that's in the process of being
made
okay all right so that's happening while
you're gonna go around the country and
put your best foot forward and go get
drafted somewhere pretty much that's
what you're saying yes sir i uh
i got some um
i got i got some ideas of about the suit
and just you know some ole miss memories
maybe okay
all right we got that we got that all
we'll we'll take a look out for all of
that hey matt um
good luck to you i look forward to
spending more time on the phone or here
in person
um here in southern california anytime
you want good luck to you i look forward
to seeing you right now appreciate it
thank you for having me on that
absolutely man i look forward to
thursdays and sundays and mondays and
what have you with you matt corral let's
let's do it thanks for the call
thank you take care that's matt corral
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here